-Hey, what's up, Jim?
What's going on, buddy?
-It's so good to see you.
Man, it has been a while
since the first time I told you
the first I saw you was at my
high school in Saugerties.
-Yeah, that's pretty awesome,
Saugerties.
-Yeah, it was like
a Golden Glove
or something like that.
-I don't know.
Probably was just a local
amateur fight or something.
-Yeah, and I remember our
local shoe store, Montano's,
sold you a pair of boxing shoes
or something like that,
and I was like --
I love that you got --
like, that was a big legend
around my hometown growing up
was that, "Mike Tyson got his
boxing shoes from Montano's!"
It was the coolest thing ever.
And now, here you are,
Mike Tyson is back.
Iron Mike. September 12th.
-Oh, man, I'm so happy.
Yeah, man.
It's gonna be so awesome.
I'm so happy
to be coming back into the ring
and facing Roy Jones
on September 12th.
It's gonna be so awesome.
And by doing that, I'm also --
Jimmy, I'm gonna be launching --
Being the prototype of it,
I'm launching
my Legends Only League.
And this is gonna be so awesome.
Other leagues from all over --
whoever, I don't care.
Basketball, pool shark,
all the ex-legends
who want to play
and still able to play
and still beautiful,
like myself,
they can come with us,
they can call me.
We can have anybody.
Like, before, I was saying,
we have Dennis Rodman go against
Metta World Peace, one on one,
have Wayne Gretzky go against
an up-and-coming young guy,
one on one,
have their team together.
Everybody.
-That's a great idea.
But this is, like --
How'd it come about,
first fight in 15 years?
How did it happen?
Why?
-Well, I don't know.
I wanted to do something good.
I'm embarked
on a real charitable event,
and oh, man, we're gonna help
so many various charities.
And I thought
it was a great thing to do.
And, of course,
I can still do it, of course.
So, this is what I want to do.
I'm really
looking forward to it.
-And did you pick Roy Jones Jr.
out of a lineup?
'Cause you could fight anyone.
-Hey, I don't know.
It's a whole bunch of guys.
It started out with Bob Sapp,
and I got from Bob Sapp
to Roy Jones.
I don't know how this happened,
but I think he's brilliant,
'cause he's the greatest fighter
of his generation.
I'm the greatest fighter
of my generation,
and it's just a no-brainer that
we should clash together.
-Yeah. You guys
never fought before, right?
-No, we planned on fighting,
but it didn't happen,
but this is the opportunity now.
-I saw the training footage
of you on Instagram,
and, oh, my gosh!
You've got it, man.
It's unbelievable.
-I'm back, man, I'm back.
I don't know how come
it came back.
I started training.
I'm back in shape. I'm 228.
And I've been boxing.
Doing what I can.
I can't believe
this either, man.
It's just -- I don't believe
in the Fountain of Youth,
but something just came over me,
and I'm back, man.
-How does it feel training from
54 compared to when you were 24?
-Well, it's really painful.
-[ Laughing ]
-Really painful.
And from
this experience right now,
I'll never call
another fighter a bum again,
because anybody that does this
or attempts to do this
is no bum.
-Yeah, it's tough.
It's rough.
How do your kids
feel about you coming back?
-Well, my kids think
I should sit my old ass down,
but what do they know?
Of course. You know?
I'm very confident.
They don't know how to fight.
Neither one of my kids
can beat me in a fight,
so what are they talking about?
-Yeah, exactly.
What are they talking about?
Yeah. Come on.
-Wait till they see
what dad does.
-Absolutely.
-I have a prediction.
-I think -- well, I know you're
gonna win because I know you.
You're Mike Tyson.
I think --
How long is a round?
Three minutes?
-Three minutes.
Three minutes.
-I think, here's what happens.
I think, in your head,
you're gonna
want to go five rounds.
But I think once you get in
there and that thing
and you get tagged once,
the hurricane's gonna come out,
the Iron Mike
is gonna come out,
and you're gonna lose it.
I'm gonna say...fourth round.
And that's being nice.
-Well, why don't we just
do a lottery and find out.
-Yeah. Oh, definitely.
I'll fly to you.
-Absolutely.
This is gonna be so awesome.
-"Iron Mike" --
did that come from Cus D'Amato?
Where'd you get the nickname
"Iron Mike"?
-Somebody just started
calling me "Iron Mike,"
a gentleman that hung out with a
friend of mine, Carlos Santos.
And he had said,
"Man, I'll buy you a T-shirt
that says 'Iron Mike.'
I didn't even know what
that stands for, and now
everybody calls me "Iron Mike."
-Wow.
See, I didn't know that.
And then I just saw
some pictures of Jamie Foxx,
who is unbelievable.
I love that guy.
He's so talented.
He's playing you in a movie
called "Finding Mike."
It's finally happened.
We talked about it last time
you were on the show.
And so now
it's finally happening.
-Hey, man,
I'm looking forward to this.
This is gonna be really
interesting, observing myself.
-Yeah. But Jamie said to me
when he was here last time,
we're talking in the hallway,
and he said,
"I got tons of Mike stories.
Like, we hung out.
I've been through everything."
Like, he was with you
through the good times
and the bad times.
-Jamie might also
be participating
in the Legends Only League,
as well, because I'm sure
there's some comedians
that want to kick his ass.
-[ Laughing ]
-So we can get Jamie
to participate
in this stuff, as well.
Listen, it's for all athletes.
I'm talking about anybody --
ping pong players,
all legendary handball players,
all the legends of the past,
you know,
who's around 45, 50 years old.
Come with me.
Tell your agents to call me.
Get in shape.
I'm talking about anybody.
I don't care who you are.
Everybody.
We can always
have something for you.
Legends don't have to stand out.
Of course, if they're still
beautiful, like myself,
and still able to do
what they do,
so why do they have to
not do what they do?
You can still have
a great football team,
basketball team,
one-on-one tennis,
one-on-one ping pong, whatever,
handball, whatever.
Basketball, football.
Whatever it is, we got it.
-Yeah, just because
you got older,
doesn't mean
you're not still an athlete.
-Exactly!
How many people you know
can still outrun Jerry Rice,
really?
-No. No one.
-Exactly.
-No one I know.
And I bet you --
And I bet you he has
more fan bases
and more YouTube followers
than the guy that plays
his position
in the team he used to play for.
-Yeah. Yeah,
I think it's a great idea.
-Exactly.
He doesn't have to die.
Why does he have to die because
they say he can't play no more?
-[ Laughing ] Exactly.
I'm so excited about this.
September 12th.
And if anyone needs
any more reason be to excited
for the fight,
take a look at this.
-Why do I want to be
the baddest man on the planet?
Sometimes I wish I could stop
having these desires
to go forward,
to think that I'm somebody,
'cause it's a lot of work.
-You got to be willing
to get up every morning, 5:00,
hit that rope, every day.
Certain time, hit that gym.
Because that other man over
there is willing to do anything
that he got to do necessary
to win.
-Human beings are not
meant to be humble.
-Nobody ever went
from junior middleweight
and became heavyweight champ.
I took off and did it.
-We're not born to be humble.
We born to be humbled.
-It's like David and Goliath.
He's this monster we know.
If he hits you,
he can take your head off,
and I'm little old David
who only has God on my side.
-Tell me
who you want me to kill.
-That's what I'm talkin' about.